a few weeks ago we built a graph QL
server with Apollo and nodejs if you
haven't seen that video make sure to
check that one out first to get a better
understanding of graph QL and Apollo
because in today's episode we're going
to be tackling the front end side of
this equation which involves querying
data and providing mutations with
optimistic updates in our angular app if
you're new here make sure to LIKE and
subscribe and send a thank you to Arjun
Yellen and Shelley who was responsible
for writing the code for this lesson to
get started let's first talk about why
Apollo and graph QL are awesome
technologies from the front-end
developer perspective
notice how when I click this heart
button that the count increases and then
a second later our server responds with
an error and then it revert back to the
old value that's known as an optimistic
update or latency compensation and if
you use firebase you're probably already
familiar with this because that's one of
the things that the SDK does for you
automatically but if you're not using
the firebase SDK this is a feature that
would be really difficult to implement
from scratch
Apollo angular makes it easy to
implement features like this plus we can
use it with any back-end data source
that we've set up in our graph QL server
if we open this project in be s code
you'll notice that we have a back-end
and front-end folder the backend is the
graph QL server that we built in the
first episode we'll go in there and make
some updates but for the most part will
be in the front end which is an angular
6 app in our friend and app we're going
to install Apollo angular boost which is
a client library that makes it easy to
set up graph QL on an angular app and
also a library called Apollo code gen
which will allow us to generate
typescript definitions from our server
side automatically which is another
really awesome feature that we'll see
here in a few minutes and lastly we'll
use the angular CLI to generate an NG
module for our graph QL feature then we
can go ahead and open up that module and
we'll want to import the apollo boost
library and add it to the imports array
in the ng module then we'll add a palo
boost to the constructor of this module
and call apollo boost create and then
point it to wherever our graph QL server
is being hosted in this case we're
hosting it on localhost 4000 slash graph
QL and lastly we'll make sure to import
this graph QL module inside of
or app module so that takes care of the
front end setup but now I'm going to go
into the backend and setup a mutation so
we have some data that we can actually
update in this app unlike a REST API
where we would use something like post
patch or put to update data in the
backend we just have a single mutation
query that we can make that signifies
data is going to be updated with this
query so we'll set up a mutation here
that allows a user to like a tweet to
make that possible we'll just create a
mutation type called like tweet that
takes in a tweet ID as an argument and
then returns the newly created tweet as
its response then we just need to write
a resolver for this mutation in the
resolvers we'll go ahead and create a
mutation object then give it a like
tweet function that is asynchronous
meaning it returns a promise inside this
function we perform the mutation which
is just updating the tweet like count so
we'll go ahead and make a reference to
the tweet itself then pull the current
count of tweets increment it by one then
update the data in the database and
lastly we'll return the freshest data
from the database and we'll also want to
catch any errors here and return an
Apollo error back to the client if that
update fails that takes care of the back
end now I want to show you something
really cool you can do on the front end
with the Apollo CLI which is generating
all of your type definitions in your
angular app by making a query to your
back-end server first I'm creating a new
directory called types and then we have
this big long command here that you can
copy and paste from the source code that
will generate the types as a schema JSON
file it does this by making what's
called an introspection query which is a
special thing in graph QL that will
return the entire schema of the database
to your front-end client but it's
extremely powerful if you're a front-end
developer because you now know the
entire shape of all the data that's
available in the backend so you can see
here we now have a type script type for
the tweets query that retrieves the
items from the database and then also
another one for the like tweet mutation
which will update the tweet count now
let's go ahead and put these types to
use in our app component as you saw from
the demo we need this component to loop
over an observable array of tweet
content and also update the light count
when the heart button is clicked so
we'll bring in Apollo on graph QL a few
things from our XJ
and the types that we just generated
first we'll declare a property called
tweets which is just an observable of
the tweet data then we have the tweets
query which is a graph QL object that
defines how we retrieve this from the
graph QL backend this is nice because we
can explicitly define the data that's
needed for the front-end user experience
which in this case would just be the
tweet ID the text content and the white
count the next step is to send this
query off to our back-end and return the
data as an observable so Apollo is a
service that we can inject in the
constructor and then to make a query we
can call Apollo watch query which is
just a reference and then to get an
observable back of the data we call
value changes on it then the actual
observable will contain some additional
metadata so we can just pipe that down
to the actual data that we want to show
in the front end and now we have an
observable that we can just subscribe to
with the async pipe in the HTML which
we'll see here in a minute the mutation
is similar but takes in an ID as a
variable so that value can change
depending on which heart button the user
clicks so we'll define the actual graph
QL query inside of this method which
we're calling like tweet and then it
takes in the ID as an argument and it
will return all of the new data about
that tweet including its updated light
count instead of using Apollo watch
query like we did last time this time
we'll use Apollo mutate and what's
special about this is that we can define
our own optimistic response behavior in
our case we know when the user hits the
like button it should increment the
current light count by one so by setting
up this logic we'll have that update
appear in the UI instantly in the eyes
of the user and in most cases we won't
have any errors on the back end so
they'll just stay there like it happened
instantaneously but if any kind of error
does happen it will come back and revert
to the actual value from the server so
it'll feel like that is zero latency for
your user even though in real life it
might take your server a second or two
to respond so now we can jump into the
HTML and we just have a simple
observable of tweets that we can loop
over I am wrapping it in parenthesis
then accessing its tweets property
because that's where the actual tweet
objects live then we can display the
text for each tweet and then we'll set
up a button here
we'll update the white count then below
that will display the white count which
should update instantly when this button
is clicked on my back-end code I set up
a method that will give a 50/50 chance
of throwing an error for each mutation
so the first time I click the button
that goes to 77 gets an error then
reverts back to 76 on the second attempt
we don't get nearer it stays at 77 and
then we get the tweet data logged in the
console overall Apolo gives you an
awesome way to query a graph QL API from
an angular app if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and if you
want to learn more about these
technologies consider becoming a pro
member at angular firebase comm you'll
get access to all kinds of exclusive
content and a free copy of my book
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
soon